so we're talking about possibly the most
famous equation in maths you've all
heard of it euler's identity the most
beautiful equation in all of maths e to
the i pi plus one equals zero we've got
the five most important or famous
mathematical constants zero one i pi and
the number e there's a reason this is
the most beautiful equation in maths and
the most famous probably mathematical
equation
but
there's so much more
going on here so what i really want to
talk about
is
euler's formula we need to start with
complex numbers we've got a number z
which we can write as x plus i
times y here we call x the real part of
our complex number y is the imaginary
part and the number i is the square root
of minus one now this kind of came about
because as mathematicians we wanted to
be able to solve all possible quadratic
equations so we said let's call the root
of minus 1 i and now we have a solution
to any possible quadratic equation by
the quadratic formula but the best way
to think about these is to draw a graph
we have the x-axis is the real part of z
the y-axis is the imaginary part of z
and then i can represent my complex
number as actually a point in 2d space
with coordinates x y so i go x across
let's say that's here and then i go y up
so that's going to be about there so
this position z is equal to position x y
in my 2d space and this actually
uniquely defines my complex number
because if i say to you let's go x
across here and y up there's no other
point that satisfies that particular
property or that definition now that's
one way of representing a complex number
and now there's another way which is the
polar form so for that one
we have z is equal to r e
to the i theta and here r we call this
the modulus of zed and theta represents
the argument of z now these are just
fancy words which basically the modulus
means the distance
from the origin to our complex number so
if i draw a straight line which is the
shortest distance between two points
this distance is r and that's this
modulus of z which goes here and then
theta is an angle and the angle is
important because if i just told you
we're at a distance r from the origin
then i could be here but maybe i'm up
here this is also a distance r from the
origin and in fact you're going to get a
circle all of these points will be a
distance r from the origin so we need to
also give theta this angle
so we measure that from the positive
x-axis
like so so if i specify
the distance i am from the origin and
the angle from the x-axis
there's only one point just like we
uniquely had one point by specifying
horizontal and vertical distance
so now we've got two representations
for our complex number z
so we want to compare them because
they're the same complex number and the
way you do this is actually going to be
by drawing a triangle we drop that down
create a right angle then we now know
that this distance here is x and we know
that this height here is y and then we
know that our diagonal is r so now we
can use pythagoras theorem which tells
us that x squared plus y squared is r
squared so r
has to be positive because it's a
distance
is equal
to the square root of x squared plus y
squared
so we now
if we wanted we could replace that
by this
but what we really want to do is figure
out what's happening with theta
because again we know the uh the height
here
and we know the horizontal distance and
we know r so trigonometry tells me that
cos of theta is equal to adjacent over
hypotenuse so that's x over r sine of
theta is opposite over hypotenuse that's
y over r so now we can actually say that
x is equal to r cos theta and y is equal
to r sine theta so we've got these
various relationships between x y r and
theta
and we have these two representations of
z
but if we say this is the same complex
number which on my picture it is these
all have to be equal so we have these
two representations of z so we know that
z
is equal to
the distance times e to the i theta the
polar form we also know that this is
x plus i y
but we've got these two relationships
for x and y
so let's plug those in
and get r cos theta plus i times y which
is r sine theta so if i now cancel the r
what i'm left with
is this awesome equation which is
euler's formula which is the e to the i
theta is equal to
cos theta plus i
sine
theta so that right there is euler's
formula and it comes from
complex numbers
and just drawing out some triangles and
figuring out some trigonometry now
euler's formula is awesome i love
boilers formula there's loads of really
cool stuff that we can do with this and
i'm going to show you
three i think of my favorite things that
we can do with euler's formula so we've
seen where it comes from it's all to do
with complex numbers triangles different
things
now we've got it let's play around with
it and see what we can figure out the
first thing that we're going to do is
actually consider the graphs of sine and
cos so the cos curve starts at one comes
down goes up and similarly goes down and
goes up like that and then sine same
shape but goes through zero like that
cos is what we call an even function so
this means that it's symmetric about the
y-axis so if you cover up that side if
you imagine putting a mirror here you'd
see the same thing and this tells you
that cos of positive theta here is
actually equal to cos of minus theta now
for sine
this is odd and this tells us that sine
of theta
is equal to minus sine of minus
theta so if i look at this point down
here this is one so then minus minus one
gives you one which is the one you get
up here so it's minus sine of minus
theta
now we can use these two relationships
to get a really neat expression for cos
and sine because we've got this form for
e to the i theta and if we look at e to
the minus
i theta so what i'm doing really is i'm
taking theta and replacing it by minus
theta
in the top
and then i do the same in here so this
is cos of minus theta
plus i sine of minus theta
so that's just taking euler's formula
replace theta by minus theta in all
three places we have this result but
then we know that cos of minus theta
because cos is even you get cos theta
sine of minus theta sine is odd sine of
minus theta would be minus
sine of theta if i sort of do that
multiplied by both by minus 1.
so that's minus i sine of theta and now
comparing this equation and this one we
can add them together so e to the i
theta
plus e to the minus i theta so i've got
a cos theta and then i've got another
cos theta so what i'm actually going to
do is divide by 2 because i know what's
happening
and that gives me single cos theta and
then i've got minus i sine theta plus i
sine theta so they cancel so i just get
cos theta so we've now got another
definition for the cos function
this thing that we've seen the graph of
and that we use in trigonometry purely
in terms of e
and i
so it's a really nice i really like this
because you're taking this thing to do
with triangles and this wave like
function and you're now expressing it in
terms of euler's number
naturally appearing and also this
imaginary number i
and then we can do the same
with uh to get an expression for sine of
theta so we have to just subtract them
to make them cancel so you do e to the i
theta
minus e to the minus i theta because now
that one's positive and that's now
negative because we're subtracting this
one and then you've got i sine theta
minus another one so that becomes plus
2i sine theta so you have to divide by
2i
to get sine theta so we have a similar
expression so we can write cos and sine
both in terms of the exponential
function so that's my first favorite
thing to do with euler's formula now
this leads us
into
my second favorite thing to do with
euler's formula which is uh to do with
infinite series
so we're going to start with the
infinite series for the exponential
function i mentioned this before
actually in the video on domes e to the
x we can write as 1 plus x plus x
squared over 2 factorial plus x cubed
over 3 factorial x 4 over 4 factorial
and this carries on forever so this is
just a way of writing out e to the power
of some number we can write it in this
infinitely long string of pieces added
together and what this means is that the
graph of e
because we keep adding things starts
really small goes through one and then
shoots up like exponential growth so
that's what's happening with this
function now we want to figure out what
e to the i theta and e to the minus i
theta are in this form and then if we
add them together
the plan is we can now get infinite
series for cos and sign another way of
representing these cool trigonometric or
wave-like functions as an infinite
series based on what we have for the
exponential here
so we need to calculate e to the i theta
so that's just going to be
one then we replace x with i theta plus
i theta plus i theta squared over two
factorial plus i theta cubed
etc
and what we need to know is what's
happening when we square and cube i
that's the key thing because we know
that i
is the square root of minus one
so that means that i squared
is minus one
so that means that i cubed
is i squared times i so that's minus i
and then i to the fourth
that's i cubed times i which is minus i
times i which is
minus i squared which is one
because i squared is minus one so we've
got this little like cycle between the
numbers so you start with i then you
multiply by i to go to minus one then
you multiply by i to go to minus i then
you multiply by i to go to one because
that was i to the fourth and then you
multiply by i again you get back there
so it actually creates a cycle every
fourth power of i
comes back on itself so we can use this
in our infinite expansion so now we can
plug this nice cycle into our formula so
what we're going to get is e to the i
theta
is we've got a 1 plus i theta plus i
squared theta squared but i squared was
minus one so that's minus theta squared
two factorial then the cubed was minus i
so then it'll be minus i and we've still
got the theta cubed over three factorial
and then the last one the fourth one was
one so that's now plus theta to the
fourth over four factorial and then the
pattern carries on so the next one would
have an i in front of it and be a theta
to the five over five factorial and then
a minus and then a minus sign then a one
and then repeating this cycle now we
want to do the same for e to the minus
i theta
and in order to do that we need to know
powers of minus i
so we've got minus i
then we want to now do minus i squared
so that's minus i times minus i which is
going to be plus i squared which is
minus 1. then we've got minus i cubed is
minus 1 times another minus i so that
gives me a minus 1 times a minus so i'm
going to write this out that's 1 times y
psi
so they give you a plus so that's just i
and then we multiply again my side to
the fourth is going to now be minus i
squared which is minus -1 which is 1.
and then we're going to get back again
so just like before we start at minus i
we multiply by i to get minus 1. we
multiply by i to get i
and again by sorry by minus i to get i
by minus i to get one and then by minus
i let's go back so it's the same kind of
idea except two key things
this started at i this starts at minus i
then it's the same
those are different
that's the same
so in our formula what we're going to
get is e to the minus i theta is 1 minus
i theta then it didn't change so it's
still minus theta squared over 2
factorial then it was now plus
i theta cubed with 3 factorial and then
plus p to the fourth over four factorial
and the pattern repeats so now
the big result
what we were trying to get with our
infinite series
is we said that cos theta
was
e to the i theta plus e to the minus i
theta over
two
so let's add them together
so one plus one is two divided by two
one
i theta
minus i theta disappears so we get no
term there
minus theta squared
minus another theta squared is minus two
theta squared but then we divide by two
so i get minus theta squared
two factorial
theta cubed term cancel opposite sign
and then we get uh theta to the fourth
over four factorial and this carries on
so what we're seeing here is the cos
term has all of the even powers of theta
and there was a bit of a clue earlier
when we had the graph of cos when we
said it was even this doesn't prove it
by any stretch but even an even it's
nice so we've got all the even powers
for cos and we do the exact same with
sine of theta
but this time we do e to the i theta
minus
minus sine theta
over 2i
so the first term they subtract each
other to give zero
this one minus this one gives me 2i
theta
divided by 2i so i just get theta
that one minus this one comes a plus so
they cancel
minus i
minus another i
so that gives me minus 2i theta cubed
divided by 2i so i get minus theta cubed
over 3 factorial and then that will
carry on as well in the same way so we
get power 1 power 3 power 5. we get all
the odd powers for our sine series so
just like the exponential term is
written here as 1 plus x plus x squared
cubed divided by the factorials cos and
sine causes all of the even powers where
you alternate it goes minus plus minus
plus minus plus and sine is all the odd
powers going plus minus plus minus plus
minus
so from the infinite series for the
exponential function we now get these
nice infinite series for cos and theta
and this is why sine of theta is often
approximated by just theta if you're an
engineer because it's the first term in
your infinite expansion
all right
you seem excited by that
i i love infinite series i i think
infinite the fact that you can take
this function that looks like a wave or
this function that's to do with
triangles and write it as an infinite
things added together
it still blows my mind like i know it's
true because i've just hopefully
convinced you that it's true but it's
still i don't know is this things like
this with maths that excite me like
talking about infinity and it's actually
making sense i think it's just really
amazing we've been able to do this so
the big finale actually um should we get
one final piece of paper more paper
so we've seen hopefully some really cool
stuff involving euler's formula we
derived it e to the i theta using
complex numbers we showed this was cos
theta plus i sine theta we then played
around with some infinite series and i
got very excited and now what we want to
do i did promise you we were going to do
some cool stuff around euler's identity
so this is the key euler's formula is
really the foundations behind euler's
identity identity is like the pretty
facade of the building that everyone
loves but the heavy lifting is being
done by euler's formula
and to get it you just substitute in a
value of theta
you just plug in theta equals pi
so
e to the i pi
is equal to cos of pi
plus i
times sine of phi and now if we look at
our graphs we can read off the value of
cos cos of pi is minus one sine of pi is
zero so e to the i pi according to
euler's formula is minus one which we
rearrange
to get e to the i pi plus one equals
zero
euler's identity now that's my favorite
form of it some of you might prefer the
e to the i pi equals minus one but i
quite like getting the zero in there
yeah it needs a zero for me i think i
agree this is this is the one i got
tattoo this is this is the one
now you can plug in other values of
theta this is why i wanted to share with
you all euler's formula because you can
plug in any value of theta and create
your own identity
of this kind of form we can plug in pi
by 2 which is 90 degrees and we get e to
the i pi by 2 is cos of pi by 2 well
that's zero and then plus i sine of pi
by 2 sine of pi by 2 is 1. so e to the i
pi by 2
is i so that's a nice alternative
definition of i which has come from the
same formula as orders identity did
we can then try 45 degrees so that's pi
by 4 so that's halfway up here so e to
the i pi by 4 equals cos of pi by 4
which is root 2 over 2 and then sine of
pi by 4 is actually the same value and
this
is very nice because this number is
actually equal to
the square root of i
i to the half because what you do is you
take this formula and if you take i to
the power of a half that means
multiplying this by a half which gives
you e to the i pi by four so this is
another way of showing the square root
of i
is given by
one plus i or multiplied by root 2 over
2. and then the final two that we might
want to look at are going to be 60
degrees so that's pi over 3 so e to the
i pi over 3 is going to be cos of 60
so cos of 60 is quite far down so cause
it's quite small so that's a half plus i
times
sine of
60 so that's root three over two and
then the last one which is my favorite
pi by six or 30 degrees
so i like this one because you bring in
a six which is a new number we haven't
seen any of our other identities and
that's going to be cos of 30 is root 3
over 2
and then sine of 30
is a half so we get all of these sort of
other
identities using our most popular
numbers from triangles let's say you get
euler's identity when it's pi when it's
90 degrees
you get a definition of i you get the
square root of i when you have 45
degrees that's quite neat and then we
have these two which i like because you
just bring in all of these other numbers
so you have this really cool
relationship between six two three i e
all kinds of things you know what you
have to call the sixth one the sexy
identity
all right so we've got euler's identity
and then we've got the sexy identity e
to the i five by six is root three over
two plus psi over two that is that is
screaming sex appeal to me
if you like this video you're probably
gonna like all the courses and learning
to be had at brilliant brilliance
crammed with interactive content that'll
expand your mind make you smarter and
also well it's just kind of fun
do you think you get this one
now watching videos is great i'm glad
you do it but nothing helps you learn
better than actually interacting with
problems
like this
[Music]
see it all at brilliant.org or to get 20
off the full premium all-inclusive
subscription
use the url brilliant.org
number file it's there on the screen and
in the description if you're already a
subscriber and frankly why wouldn't you
be then it's also a really great gift
for the learner in your life
you couldn't use any ideas that had gone
before either so you had to really do
something new you could only write down
finite numbers so you can't be writing
down infinite ordinals or anything like
that it's just finite numbers we're
allowed